I believe you have a role to play as
does another the king in the north
Jon Snow hey everybody there's a whole
bunch of new Game of Thrones season 8 to
break down so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm still doing that book
giveaway to all explain at the end of
the video most of the main stars have a
bunch of other projects going on like
sophie turner has x-men dark phoenix so
give me all your Sansa unburnt jokes
people were asking her about Game of
Thrones Season eight so naturally she
explains some of the timeline when it's
gonna drop she confirmed that it would
not drop until 2019 which effectively
means that it'll drop April May 2019 now
they could always drop it as early as
March but typically you don't see HBO
dropping its major major series in
January or February so that's why I'm
not expecting it till April but if you
haven't seen the video I did for their
shooting schedule I'll link that at the
end of this but Leanne Cunningham
basically says that they're filming
right up until June of next year so in
terms of principal photography they have
a long way to go the practical reason
for why it's taking so much longer is is
because they don't have a third or even
a fourth film unit that can film scene
simultaneously while their main unit is
doing stuff because everybody is
localized to the same two big places
Winterfell and King's Landing so you
just have a lot of people in shots they
have to film the shots from multiple
different angles which means a bunch of
setups which means it just takes much
longer to get through scenes the other
big side of that is that it's gonna take
extra long in post-production because
you have a bunch of dragons fighting in
the sky imagine three dragons fighting
each other because you have the night
king of bazarian then you have drogon
and ragle it took a long time for them
to do scenes like the night king of
vissarion just one dragon in one person
or Daenerys and Rogan then you have
episode six when you actually do have
the three dragons on screen briefly just
imagine the uber version of that with
one of them looking vastly different
it's a little bit easier when all their
models look relatively similar but as
you go back and you watch the previous
seasons you see there's this exponential
increase in the level of detail in their
dragon model so not only are the dragons
getting bigger they're also looking
better and better from a CG perspective
the side benefit of Game of Thrones
spending millions and millions of HBO
dollars blazing those digital trails is
that it becomes exponentially cheaper to
do that exact same thing just a year
later so whatever they end up going with
for that prequel series it'll be much
much easier and much much cheaper for
them to do big crazy stuff like this but
now because confirmed no new game of
thrones during 2018 they will probably
drop a lot more behind the scenes promos
like they did in the lead up to season 7
so we'll get to see what's going on
it'll just take a little bit longer to
actually get the episodes the composer
Ramin Djawadi made this offhanded
comment about how his music to her this
season would be kind of like a trailer
for season 8 this is what the actors
actually said about their specific story
lines starting with sophie turner so
this is me quoting her things are going
to be different for Sansa now that
Littlefinger is gone but that doesn't
mean that it won't get any easier for
her it's going to be tricky for her
because at the end of last season she
felt like she had everything set up she
had her family back together they were
in control of the North again this
season there's a new threat and all of a
sudden she finds herself somewhat back
in the deep end and without Littlefinger
it's a test for her of whether she can
get through it it's a big challenge for
her without this master manipulator
having her back the thing that a lot of
people forget is that for a couple
seasons Littlefinger was whispering in
her ear just inception her with ideas
giving her counsel chiana's the latter
so she made you write to provide proof
of my betrayals to provide justification
after she Mondas me and office you might
as you
what has she become
they do wonderful
No That's not me
so it really wasn't until that turn
during the end of season seven where she
sensed that he was trying to manipulate
her and she suddenly realized what was
going on and turned on him so at the
beginning of the season when she's
arguing about getting rid of the
Karstarks in the umbers you wonder if
Littlefinger had something to do with
sowing that dissent like you see him
just carefully weighing the room in the
background until John snow comes back
with Daenerys she's de facto leader of
the north so the question is is who does
she listen to and who does she turn to
for advice
turnip bran can tell her anything she
wants to know but she has to ask him the
right questions and she probably doesn't
always know what those are
so Samwell can help out with that
because John Bradley the actor did say
that the team of bran and Sam will
continue to be a big thing during season
eight he said specifically and I'm
quoting him what I think links those two
characters is that they're both
characters who are in possession of
abilities and skills nobody else has
between them there's such a formidable
team because okay they can't fight
between them like physically fight they
don't have much physical power between
them but both of their set of skills are
so unique
Sam's penchant for absorbing knowledge
and absorbing academia and his wish to
apply that for the greater good
combined with brands visions and
supernatural skills mean that between
the two of them it's a real recipe for
success he should also have probably
said under his breath a recipe for
disaster
because misinterpreting visions has been
a big thing in Game of Thrones
Melisandre is the best example of that
visions prophecies can be a tricky thing
and you believe this prophecy refers to
me prophecies are dangerous things I
believe you have a role to play the
follow-up for that especially the Sansa
unburn you think about what's going on
with the red priestesses she went to
volantis she's probably going to come
back with some of the fiery hand in tow
which is the fighting arm of the red
priests and Canberra who sort of the
more powerful version of Melisandre
because I know everybody wonders how the
faith is going to weigh in on this war
you've had a couple of
priests and priestesses parroting
prophecy for the last couple of seasons
now it's time for them to show in force
and help out the latest big new force
that we know that they've cast for the
show is the golden company they haven't
said anything about actually bringing
the fiery hand on the show and they
haven't been seen on set so we'll see if
that changes but they just have to
invoke the power of the faith at some
point in addition to all these regular
people coming together so here's my big
question for you let me know in the
comments what do you want HBO to do
during 2018 to keep the hype alive for
season eight now they have Westworld
coming and we don't know exactly when
winds of winter is going to drop george
RR martin hasn't said anything specific
about that but it's always possible that
we could get new book material so that
would help fill the gap but it just
feels like HBO will have to go above and
beyond to try and do something to keep
the fans happy so there is a new round
of the giveaway and actually all say
it's for the DVD because they actually
just dropped the season 7 DVD all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from my
last game of Thrones video zombie who
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to watch sir Davos explain the season 8
schedule and you can click here to learn
about all the new characters that are
coming on thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight